las redadas israelíes en poblaciones
palestinas no cesan Y la que nos ocupa
hoy tuvo lugar en el campo de refugiados
en el área cisjordana de Jericó allí el
ejército israelí mató a cinco palestinos
de entre 21 y 28 años en concreto cinco
miembros que ya han sido revindicados
por jamás en un operativo que tenía como
foco un pequeño grupo armado ligado
precisamente a este movimiento islamista
según Israel entre los fallecidos dos
serían los responsables del intento de
ataque a un restaurante en un
asentamiento israelí cercano esto pasó
el 28 de enero sin víctimas mortales
debido a que falló el arma de fuego pero
todo esto asumido a Jericó enredadas
enfrentamientos y un bloqueo que hoy
precisamente cumple 10 días desde
entonces las fuerzas israelíes han
reforzado los controles en las entradas
a esta ciudad lo que ha causado filas de
varias horas y según el gobernador local
también un gran costo para comercios
agricultura y también turismo recordemos
que Jericó es una ciudad que suele
quedar más alejada de la violencia pues
atrae a turistas que vienen a visitar
los sitios culturales y religiosos de la
ciudad antigua sin embargo tras esta
redada la ciudad Se declaró en huelga y
algunos jóvenes palestinos quemaron
neumáticos para interrumpir una de esas
entradas así en total ya son 41 los
palestinos muertos por fuego israelí
hasta 2023 mientras el líder de jamás ha
advertido que esta redada podría afectar
las conversaciones en curso con Egipto
para evitar una violencia todavía mayor